[Music]  billboards aimed at preventing the next  fentanyl overdose are up across town  thanks to christina perkins her 17 year  old son geo took a pill that he thought  was for pain  turned out it was illicit fentanyl geo  never woke up  perkins is using her pain to try and  prevent the same thing from happening to  other families  it's probably the worst thing  that you'll ever ever ever ever  experience in your life  it's not like a kid losing their parent  losing a child is just unexplainable  she is paying for and has raised money  for these signs with her son's picture  they say one pill will kill she hopes to  have them in place for about a year